intelligence as computational
sophistication is much broader
than uh yes then the the computational
constraints
which
consciousness operates under and also
the sequential like the sequential thing
yes like the notion of time
that's that's kind of interesting but
then the the follow-up question is like
okay starting to get a sense of what is
intelligence
and how does that connect to a human
brain because you're saying
um
intelligence is almost like a fabric
like what we like plug into it or
something like i think you know our
consciousness plugs into it yeah i mean
the intelligence i think the core
i mean you know intelligence some level
is just a word but we're asking you know
what is the the notion of intelligence
as we generalize it beyond the bounds of
humans beyond the bounds of even the ais
that we humans have built and so on you
know what what is intelligence you know
is the weather you know people say the
weather has a mind of its own what does
that mean you know can the weather be
intelligent
yeah what does agency have to do with
intelligence here so is intelligence
just like your conception of computation
just intelligence
is a
is the capacity to perform computation
in the sea of yeah i think so i mean i
think that's right and i i think that
you know this question of of is it for a
purpose okay
that quickly degenerates into a horrible
philosophical mess because you know
whenever you say
did the weather do that for a purpose
yeah right well yes it did it was trying
to move a bunch of hot air from the
equator to the poles or something that's
its purpose but why because i seem to be
equally as dumb today as i was yesterday
so there's some persistence uh like uh
consistency over time that the
intelligence i plugged into
so like what's it seems like there's a
hard constraint
the amount of computation i can perform
in my consciousness
like they seem to be really closely
connected somehow well i think the point
is that the thing that gives you kind of
the ability to have kind of conscious
intel intelligence
you you can have kind of this okay so so
one thing is we don't know
intelligences other than the ones that
are very much like us yes right and the
ones that are very much like us i think
have this feature of single thread of
time
bounded you know computationally bounded
now that but you also need computational
sophistication having a single thread of
time and being computationally bounded
you could just be a clock going
tick-tock you know that would satisfy
those conditions but the fact that we
have this uh sort of uh irreducible
you know computational ability that's
that's an important feature that's
that's the sort of the the bedrock on
which we can construct the things we
construct now the fact that we have this
experience of the world that has a
single thread of time and computational
boundedness
the thing that i sort of realized is
it's that that causes us
to deduce from this irreducible mess of
what's going on in the physical world
the laws of physics that we think exist
so in other words if we say why do we
believe that there is you know
continuous space let's say why do we
believe that gravity works the way it
does
well in principle we could be kind of
parsing details of the universe
that were uh you know that
okay the analogy is uh again with the
the you know statistical mechanics and
molecules in a box we could be sensitive
to every little detail of the swirling
around those molecules and we could say
what really matters
is the you know the wiggle effect yes
that is um you know that is something
that we humans just never notice because
it's some weird thing that happens when
there are 15 collisions of air molecules
and this happens and that happens we
just see the pure motion of a ball yeah
moving about right why do we see that
right and the point is that that what
seems to be the case is that the things
that if we say given this sort of
hypograph that's updating and all the
details about all the sort of uh sort of
atoms of space and what they do and we
say how do we slice that to what we can
be sensitive to what seems to be the
case is that as soon as we assume you
know computational boundedness single
thread of time that leads us to general
relativity in other words we can't avoid
that that that's the way that we we will
parse the universe given those
constraints we parse the universe
according to
those particular uh
in such a way that we say the aggregate
reducible compe
sort of compute pocket of computational
reducibility that we slice out of this
kind of whole computational irreducible
ocean of behavior is just this one that
corresponds to general relativity yeah
but we don't perceive general relativity
well we do if we do fancy experiments so
you're saying so perceive really does
mean the force we drop something that's
a that's a great example of general
relativity in action the gravity no but
like what's the difference between that
and newtonian mechanics i mean oh it
doesn't the this is i when i say
generalitivity that's gravity uber the
uber theory so to speak i mean newtonian
gravity is just the approximation that
we can make you know
on the earth and things like that so so
this is you know the phenomenon of
gravity is one that is a consequence of
you know we would perceive something
very different from gravity so so the
way to understand that is when we think
about okay so
we make up reference frames with which
we parse what's happening in space and
time
so in other words one of the one of the
things that we do
is we say
as time progresses
uh everywhere in space
is something happens at a particular
time and then we go to the next time and
we say this is what space is like at the
next time there's what space is like at
the next time
that's it's the reason we are used to
doing that
is because you know when we look around
we might see you know 10 100 meters away
um the time it takes light to travel
that distance is really short compared
to the time it takes our brains to know
what happened so as far as our brains
are concerned we are parsing the
universe in this there is a moment in
time it's all of space there's a moment
in time it's all of space you know if we
were the size of planets or something we
would have a different perception
because the speed of light would be much
more important to us we wouldn't have
this perception that uh things happen
progressively in time everywhere in
space
and so that's an important kind of
constraint and the reason that we kind
of parse the universe in the way that
causes us to say gravity works the way
it does is because we're doing things
like deciding that we can say the
universe exists space has a definite
structure
there is a moment in time space has this
definite structure we move to the next
moment in time space as another
structure that kind of set up is what
lets us kind of deduce
kind of what to pass the universe in
such a way that we say gravity works the
way it does so uh that kind of reference
frame is that the illusion of that
is that
you're saying that somehow useful for
consciousness
that's what consciousness does because
in a sense what consciousness is doing
is there are uh
it's it's insisting that the universe is
kind of sequentialized right that is um
and it is not allowing the possibility
that oh there are these multiple threads
of time and they're all flowing
differently it's like saying no you know
everything is happening in this one
thread of experience that we have and
that illusion of that one thread of
experience cannot happen at the
planetary scale so are you saying
typical human are you saying we are at a
human level especially
here for consciousness like well for our
kind of consciousness it's it's uh you
know if we existed at a scale close to
the elementary length for example then
our perception of the universe will be
absurdly different okay so but this
makes this consciousness seem like a
weird side effect to this particular
scale
and so who cares i mean the
consciousness is not that special i
think look i think that a very
interesting question is which i've
certainly thought a little bit about
is what can you imagine what is a sort
of factoring of something you know what
are some other possible ways you could
exist so to speak right and you know if
you were a photon if you were sort of
you know some kind of thing that was
some uh kind of you know intelligence
represented in terms of photons you know
for example the photons we receive in
the cosmic microarray background those
photons as far as they're concerned the
universe just started they they were
emitted you know 100 000 years after the
beginning of the universe they've been
traveling at the speed of light times
stayed still for them and then they just
arrived and we just detected them so for
them the universe just started and
that's a different perception of you
know that has implications for a very
different perception of time i don't
have that single thread that seems to be
really important for being able to tell
a heck of a good story so we humans yeah
we can tell a story
right we can tell a story what other
kind of stories can you tell so photon
is a really boring story
yeah i mean so that's a i don't know if
they're a boring story but i i think
it's you know i've been wondering about
this and i've been asking you know
friends of mine who are science fiction
writers and things have you written
stuff about this and i've got one
example good great great uh collection
of books from my friend rudy rooker
which were um uh which i have to say the
um they're books about uh that are very
informed by a bunch of science that i've
done and the thing that i really loved
about them is you know you know in the
in the first chapter of the book the the
earth is consumed by these things he
called nance which are nano nanobot type
things
but so you know so the earth is gone in
the first but then it comes back but but
um but then spoiler alert yeah right
that was uh that was only a microspot
it's only chapter one okay it's it's um
the but but uh the thing that um is is
not a real spoiler alert because it's
such a complicated concept but but in
the end
in the end the the earth is saved by
this thing called the principle of
computational equivalence which is a
kind of a core scientific idea of mine
and i was just like like thrilled i
don't read fiction books very often um
and i was just thrilled i get to the end
of this and it's like oh my gosh you
know everything is saved by this sort of
deep scientific principle
you